vsauce kevin here imagine that a guy
transporting
thousands of birds in an enclosed truck
stopped before crossing
an old dangerous bridge his avian cargo
makes the truck too
heavy to safely cross so how could he
make it
lighter the birds what if he
banged on the side of the truck scared
the birds inside and caused them to fly
around
if they're in the air they'll weigh
nothing and he can safely cross
the bridge right the scared
angry birds are flying inside his truck
as he slowly drives over the bridge
here we go
[Music]
uh oh don't worry don't worry uh
i'm sure the truck driver and the birds
are fine the bridge
not doing quite as well why didn't his
plan
work because he didn't account for the
unseen
physics of bird flight excuse me bridge
to fly a bird has to generate enough
lift and thrust to counteract drag and
its body weight
we can calculate that by making weight w
which equals 0.3
a constant value related to the angle of
attack which is the angle of its wings
relative to the air usually 6 degrees or
so
multiplied by the air speed v times the
mass flow of air
which is air speed v times air density
d multiplied by s which is the surface
area of their wing
and you know what look
calculations aside i like to think of
this riddle as
thousands of uncaged birds just freaking
out
and flapping their wings inside this
truck
some birds are generating a downward
force on the air to create
the thrust and lift that gets them up
off the truck bed
some are flying horizontally and they're
using thrust and lift to stay in the air
and others get in the air and free fall
which reduces the overall load in the
truck
by their full bird weight
the important part is that even though
the truck driver can't see it
air is a fluid and these birds are
throwing physical forces around in every
direction as they move
within that fluid since he's got
thousands of birds in a closed truck
those forces are going to balance out so
that the truck's weight
is basically the same with the birds
flying around
as it was with them just sitting there
it's easy to understand his logic though
thousands of birds are heavy get them up
in the air
and they won't be but seeing the
unseen like the forces of flight
requires a high degree of abstract
thinking
and that's a pretty new concept not like
last year knew but like 50
000 years ago knew when homo sapiens
separated itself from other hominins
by entering the era of behavioral
modernity abstract thinking is
really hard to do we're thousands of
years past the stone age and
we still encounter everyday paradoxes
because
we often miss but we can't
see the truck driver's eyes couldn't
show him all the complexities of bird
flight
physics i can't see time
that's not a weird thing to admit
because
nobody can sure we can look at a clock
or notice the effects of time on things
like the changing of seasons but
we can't actually see the dimension
of time we see representations of time
and even those can be deceiving
here's an example you hate your evil
identical twin
you want him out of your life at least
for a little while so you put him on a
ship to the nearest planetary system
while you stay on earth my
evil identical twin is named bevin
that short for a trip for bad cabin
beven alpha centauri is about 4.4
light years away if i put beven on a
ship called v
space 2 and sent him off at say 0.8
c that's 80 percent of the speed of
light he'll get to alpha centauri in
5.5 years if bevin plants a flag
and then flies back he would return in
11 years
for me eleven
kevin years distance and also
time seems to work differently for bevin
from his point of view traveling at 0.8
times the speed of light
makes bevin's distance contract to just
2.64
light years which means it takes him
just 3.3
years each way to bevin his
trip only took 6.6
years my 11 years of
freedom from bevin were only 6.6 years
of
banishment to him which means my
identical twin is now 4.4 years
younger than me that unseen element of
time
just wasn't the same for us
since we can't actually travel at
luminal speeds
yet we have to explore special
relativity in the lab and
in our minds and sometimes that's a good
thing because
seeing can deceive us it's
why i burnt my burger the higher the
heat the better
right i could see the outside of the
burger cooking fast in the pan
but that char is actually making heat
conductivity to the center
happen less smoothly instead of engaging
the mired reaction that combines
sugars and amino acids to bring out the
flavors higher heat just
scorches the outside without cooking the
center evenly it tastes bad and
the inside is still pretty raw
we can get food poisoning because our
eyes aren't very good at
thermodynamics but what if you're the
hamburger
and you want to stay uncooked
[Music]
metal even though metal conducts heat to
cook things like burgers metal also
protects against unseen heat
thermal energy that comes in the form of
infrared radiation
exists just below red on the visible
spectrum
of light and infusing protective gear
with
reflective metal repels infrared
radiation
like this aluminized emergency blanket
which reflects about 95 percent of
radiated heat
nasa invented metallized polyethylene
terephthalate
for space but i use it
to look nice
when it comes to birds in a truck evil
twins traveling the cosmos or cooking
burgers
what you see is not always
what you get here i'll draw two straight
lines
there now just count the lines
one two
three even what
appears to be the simplest visible truth
can be filled with complexity that we
can only see
when we admit
that we can as always
thanks for watching
you